un dossier ukrainien fragilise davantage
les relations entre la russie et les
occidentaux
li terme ans la situation est compliquée
sur place des bombardements ont été
entendus hier moscou s'inquiète et
aujourd'hui cela semble continuer on en
parle avec antoine perraud notre envoyé
spécial à donner à ce qu
bonjour antoine alors les bombardements
qui ont commencé hier se poursuivent à
calais la situation sur place
en effet beaucoup de bombardements hier
dans la journée en particulier dans la
matinée d'hier mais aussi aujourd'hui
encore une fois dans la matinée mais on
vient de l'apprendre il ya tout juste
quelques minutes le dirigeant de la
république populaire autoproclamé de
donniez sq de nice poutine dans une
vidéo a fait une déclaration il a
annoncé l'évacuation de la population de
cette république populaire de donetsk
vers la russie n'a qu'une évacuation
temporaire car elle estime que le danger
que le cren passe à l'offensive et trop
important je vous propose d'écouter un
extrait de son intervention
ou à partir d'aujourd'hui 18 février une
évacuation massive et centralisée de la
population vers la fédération de réussir
a été organisé les femmes les enfants et
les personnes âgées seront les premiers
à être évacués nous vous invitons à en
tenir compte et à prendre la bonne
décision une évacuation temporaire
permettra de sauver votre vie et votre
santé ainsi que celle de vos proches en
accord avec les autorités de la
fédération de russie des points
d'accueil et d'hébergement été mise en
place pour nos citoyens dans la région
de rostov les personnes évacuées
recevront tout ce dont elles auront
besoin pour effectuer un déplacement
rapide toutes les conditions ont été
créées au point de contrôle où le
parcours pour choeur formé au four or ce
n'est pour l'instant qu'une déclaration
unilatérale de la part du dirigeant de
la république autoproclamée de deux
nièces que moscou n'a pas encore
confirmé sainte cette information
confirmée confirmé cette évacuation de
la population de données est vers la
vers la russie vers les régions voisines
de rostov en particulier simplement le
porte-parole du kremlin disait ce matin
il se disait très préoccupé de la
situation actuelle dans le donbass et du
côté de kiev les autorités les autorités
ukrainiennes ont fait savoir qu'elles
n'avaient nullement l'intention de
passer à l'offensive dans le donbass
écoutez
la principale cible de cette attaque
étaient des civils c'est un crime de
guerre est une provocation ouverte
garder la tête froide les provocations
ne cesseront pas nous renforcerons notre
défense mais nous n'avons pas
l'intention de mener une quelconque
offensive nous observons les unités
militaires russes dont les forces
terrestres s'élève à 129 me si on y
ajoute la composante navale et aérienne
elles atteignent 149 mille je rappelle
donc cette information qui vient de
tomber il ya quelques minutes le
président le dirigeant de cette
république autoproclamée de donetsk qui
a annoncé l'évacuation de la population
une évacuation temporaire vers la russie
la russie qui n'a pas encore confirmé
cette information
merci beaucoup antoine pour ces
précisions